on a besoin de toi pour une mission on
vient de recevoir un rapport sur une
attaque jet ski impliquant des requins
tous les navires doivent cesser toute
activité dans l'eau immédiatement faites
attention aux requins ça doit être
quelque part par ici j'aurais aimé que
tu viennes avec moi
c'est la première fois qu'on voit aussi
loin il y a des choses bien plus
dangereuses que les alphas dans les eaux
profondes
il y a eu un très grave accident les
deux autres qui étaient avec moi sont
tombés et ont été mangés par des requins
et notre moteur est bloqué ça s'annonce
mal
on est en train de prendre l'eau
il y en a un autre